[Music]
all right corrine
yes corinne uh where'd you grow up where
are you from originally i'm from little
rock arkansas
rock and tell me about your family you
had both your parents when you were
young
i did have both my parents my mother
stayed gone a lot
traveling gangster style with gangsters
my father financially took care of me
i was place to place um because my
mother was in prison
and what kind of stuff was your mom
getting into
that got her into prison oh they call
her
well actually she did present time
six and six coming back home going back
and she got all the kids back but a
couple
you know someone was adopted with me i
was a mama's baby
and wanted to be with my mom um she got
a pen in the party
um no i sealed from the governor
bill clinton of arkansas and
she didn't do a lot of stuff like
robbing stealing
halloween so she told me a story
um from a family of ten
she's from a family of 14 so i had a lot
of cousins
i was into a lot of stuff basically i'm
a school
child when i went to school
what kind of kid were you in high school
uh-huh what kind of kid were you in high
school
hello hi strong i'm sorry hi
strong hi strong hi spunk i mean i
stayed in a lot of sports
activities it's like that always on the
go
but a good kid yeah basically any abuse
as a kid or anything like that
a lot of abuse because like i said my
mom stayed gone all the time
so other people would care for me even
in high school
um she didn't recently come home until i
was like
15 or 16 years old i'm 54 today
but it was rough that people care for
you
other people abusing you
one way or another like sexual abuse
sexual abuse within a family yes
um i really don't like to talk about it
i at nine at nine years old i found out
my oldest brother was he was 16.
he was um some kind of a
he had a crew it's like five guys and
they were always get together in my
mom's
project house we lived in the project so
holland court
hollow court arkansas little rock anyway
i used to rob people a pawn shop
big [ __ ] you know like that
my brother would always keep a whole box
he looks like
chess chest boxing to play that
well he's keep a lot of them
so then i followed in his room one time
and it was unlocked
he's in the shower and found out how
much black he wore
he wore a lot of black so he was a
panther
and i know what panthers are
they got jam one of them got jammed and
snitched on
everybody in the crew
one particular day i woke up
i went to school
come home my mom and my brother was gone
they went to court
there wasn't that he was indicted the
court
um testified against the whole crew
but he was the leader of the crew so
he refused to testify on the ground that
would agreement him
and it was a lot of harassment on my
brother
after they came home as i came home from
school there's a lot of commotion in my
house
police surrounding my house a project
building house
i never forget it my mom wasn't
hysterical
my brother would get all these guns
i just hope yes
i'm screaming to talk my lungs i have
two mother sisters there
mom she took all the guys from me
and they hollered i hate you i hate you
they gonna kill me they're gonna kill me
but he dated this lady he's a young guy
he didn't this old lady that was
married to a police officer
she stayed in that bar in housing i
wasn't just invited hardcore
i mean the time he ran out the front
door
trying to get to her house we always
sneaked in our house when i was
left so he went in the same way running
the police was chasing him
she needed to do it until he started
running very well my brother
ran out i did he made it to her house
i fell i cut myself right here
i don't know if i feel cut myself where
they shot me
while i grazed my bullet or what but
they shot him in the back
going through a bathroom with them
they laid over the ledge over a window
hit about 7 8
that was traumatic for me
so you lost your brother yes 16.
was nine
so as a kid i didn't know much about the
finales that was going on
and everything but
i found out how i was living
always be timmy never liked to talk
about you know today
just because of his calls and what he
did to help our family
and the people and
never be able to get over that because
he refused to tell on himself
and other people he was
murder like that that was murder
um moving right along i never got over
it still haven't
and um
[Music]
after that motion coming up my mother
wound up going back to prison
anyway
nobody never wanted to keep me in the
first place
because i always cry for my mom right
now i got this sister that's right over
me
she's puerto rican and black right we
like
two a year and a couple of weeks apart
and it's just me and her side by side
and i have older brother which we have
the same of the same father
they will always keep us three together
ten
and everybody be able to go somewhere to
live for me
so they shipped me my air by bus
you know and i said you want to keep the
corey and you're going to keep the corey
you know mom just went back to the
penitentiary you want to keep the korean
so i family everywhere
nobody wants to keep me so i wind up
with my grandmother
now being that my dad would take care of
me no matter who
no matter where no matter what happening
my grandmother wind up having me say my
girl you're gonna come to my house and
you can shut the hell up
you're gonna go to work or you're gonna
go to school you're gonna go to school
you're gonna go to work
that's what you're gonna do and i'm not
coming after you if you get into any
trouble
if i come up to you i'm gonna beat the
devil
make the life out of you well one time
came about where she actually almost did
i stabbed the guy in school in the eye
with a pencil that was the worst ass
woman in my life
my grandmother she came up there she
marched up there which was
down the street miles we lived in the
rock south side
by tadpole creek and the railroad track
so
getting to my left thing i was raised
around the railroad track
in the woods so my mother whipped me
all the way home through the schoolyard
all the way home with a shoe
first ass weapon i ever had well works
even to this day the worst so
i didn't play my grandma my grandmother
died when i was
16. she actually raised me to the point
till my mom came
my dad came painfully every month by
taxi
by her having 14 kids each one had
10 to 12 children so it's a lot of us
so i stayed into everything with
everybody i didn't like a lot of people
but i was a people person
like people close to me touched me
me touching me like getting into my head
into my life because i never know where
people was coming from being associated
with other members of my family
you know never know where they've been
who they knew so i stayed treated like
that
for a long time um
even as a teenager to young adulthood
this particular time i'm getting to be
back in my 20s
so i'm scared to do a lot of things i'm
going to school
i get my um aaa in business
downtown little rock dramas business
college
uh associate degree and um
my mom puts me in this relationship or
the situation
with a guy he was also a con man he was
a dope thing
he shot aaron you know and he messed
with a lot of gangsters that
transport so if just
to say that said that to say this my mom
put me in this fixed relationship to
deal with this man
which kept me in the bondage he didn't
let me go anywhere
without him even if he had company in
the house i could not
explore myself in my home i'd be locked
in the bedroom
or locked in the closet you know i could
go nowhere with school
my business college which i received
income from my father
but at this time i was abused a lot
he beat me a lot he didn't care where he
didn't care
who saw it or what i'm 17.
i'm going back i'm going 17 to nothing i
was like 21.
and um one day came about and i said i'm
tired of it
i went to school i left school
i wouldn't have my lawyer i went to the
police department
she got a warrant restraining order
all the whole nine yards so eventually
he got caught up in this big department
store
doing a he did a film for him in this
big
farm store so he got arrested and
somebody got hurt
or killed or something in the situation
so they asked me
they just got my retraction from the
restraining order in the police report
something living with this guy
so he wanted to go out to prison and
they asked me did i want to press
charges in the situation
so i had another charge to this case
give him more time
get him off the streets well i did that
you know i'm young i did it but it was a
lot of abuse
all i broke bones and [ __ ] like that he
taught me
but the thing about that is he wanted
him getting out he gave him 44 to life
he got out but i'm in california at that
time so i'm like i'm like 21.
but he got out he retracted his life
now you are sort of fed
he's one of my best friends i called him
today and he's running
he didn't come after you no that's right
well i i lived out here for like 22
years while i went back home
and the moment he heard i was coming
back he was like cleared the whole day
that's funny you know because he was
like oh
do a report with a rehabilitation from
prisoners
and they bought him this big old piece
of where he already had land from his
family they brought him bigger pizza
probably
more people you know like a pillow
and uh he like cleared the whole
neighborhood
and rented me a car and all he just
just cool cat who got today and still
working she's one of the kind they call
for reinforcements
you know when they need somebody
reprieve and incarceration
they open up today and let him in give
him the key
he's top-notching like feeling himself
for real but he's doing real good
support he supported his community back
where he was raised at
giving back to the people he's still an
[ __ ]
because i knew he said you always feel
no i would not
all i wanted some money that's all
so he didn't turn his life around he's a
whole different person that i knew
and uh he said but i'll never forget you
you tried to give me all that time in my
life right
you got to give me 44 years and getting
like 20 years
25 years in prison but you never let me
forget it
but yeah jump and run so
i went back home that time
came back to california because at that
time i took my son back with me to my
mom
anyway i've been through a lot of [ __ ]
um
a whole lot [ __ ] up relationships
like i dated a lot of guys you know
a little something going for themselves
i never they always had a business
or a job
um and speaking of that i got into one
relationship they brought me to
california
we called him old pro he gave me his
shotgun shack beer tablet
um he gave me his cars his cars
he worked falcon jet um
older cat you know three three was he
needed companionship
to get over some stuff of embarrassment
so
i wind up my father wanted to get sick
he wanted to take care of me i wanted to
still go into school
four hours a day cocktail waiting
another four hours
barely just because i need a
apprenticeship to you know the graveyard
and do the partnership of uh hostess
cashier in little rock on the big motel
sheraton and nowadays
so i worked up did a little president
with many people
uh in a different light of living you
know
and came so clarity would call the
school getting my my degrees
my hours and office technology so i was
intrigued about trying to do something
better with my life
um i'm still remaining teachable
to learn and education i believe
education is the most important thing to
limit
besides health mind is a terrible thing
ways
when you have time to live your mind is
i got a love for me to the simple fact i
have
more children as well
and the force of that is people forcing
me
to release parental rights when i take
care of other people
children i did some about this
i don't understand but look this is
just the nick of it they're all right
they're beautiful they've been grown up
real smart and beautiful all right how
many kids six six
six five by one men that's deceased now
and one by another i was the first man
18 years here in california
the other one for the last 15 years
oh i'm sorry phil that's good
you layer on the floor oh the other one
he's a piece of [ __ ] and when i got
pregnant with his daughter
i didn't want her because of the
possibility of the abuse they did to me
and the drugs the influence in the
streets i lived in the streets for them
cars and all this and that with the your
kids you raised how many of them
i had six um i brought two of them on
the rest of three years in the system
which the two oldest ones know me the
third one
only seen after gave birth to her one
visit to children's services
the other two um i brought my son and my
daughter
i brought home his daughter i would have
brought her home too but
his family which is his older daughter
stereotyped me
would be in them drugs and everything
possibilities when i received care
so basically it was just association in
california
that led me to not have custody of my
kids
your size my drug addiction and your
drug was crack
correct that started when for you um i
started doing crack
at an age of let me tell you i
experienced with all drugs and knives
at night i had uncles they used to play
semi-pro ball used to come back with
pounds and pounds and kilos a week and
[Music]
he played um basketball smart brook
and overseas like argentina and all that
so
nine years old nine i started doing a
16 18 crack you know hit me missing
i got strung out because they say
i'm about 20 21 well crack was the thing
when i came out here crack was the thing
uh in the late 80s i came out here in
1990
so crack was like
a god you know people would do all
and everything for that [ __ ] rock
they would do it i would do it
but not as much i uh
started not one
smoking habit to smoke crack cocaine
um it took away my pain
you know my body being a lot of trauma
in 19
in 2007 2006 i went to prison
um after being
around the wrong people getting caught
up with drugs
paraphernalia's sales and they found
color with me
you know jumping and running doing
incarceration
i wasn't doing further term of just
16-month
bid and doing um two months
when i come out the neighborhood changed
the graveyard was shut down
and i my mind just went blue i mean
i'm gonna take it james brown died right
before i got out of prison
which i was just turning around in 60
days i spent most of my time in the city
in the state
and in jail in l.a so i went to
chile when i got out james brown had
just died
so that was like a big day going on and
then i
got to the neighborhood after the great
rhyme was closed down coming from
chuckler
and i couldn't remember where
everybody went to there everybody that i
knew moved
this way people lost this and all of
that
it changed people had changed but it was
right there
i couldn't remember
so one day after being released because
we started to report which is three days
later
it's being released i had to report to
my pro-ops
the president so i'm track writing
coming in with the county building go to
the category
and after that it just went blank it's a
hot day
i'm crosstalking from all the way to
alameda i don't know if you know where
that is
and then i'm going coming back
um west east and my mind just went
blocked plucked
and i'm trying across central and lands
there
by vermin day and wlcc
it's the railroad tracks right i'm
running
running in the club i'm zig-zagging
because of the wind it was a strong wind
and a blocks sundown like
so i'm vague dazed
my foot is the railroad track
the the rail the nail
i put one in like i had on a pair of
teeny shoes like this
and i'm running just riding
i just got a breakfast like their
products
my foot went into the pin
and the wheel on the tracks but the bars
with them
well it got stuck four foot
foot between my chin
and my foot of the ankle it's a pit
in the track i can't pull it out
no i got pit i went down down
when i came to okay i was out
i don't know how many seconds but i'm
like blacked out
never hear a train coming to change the
truth
by me trotting that wasn't the thing the
thing was
i was trying to get across the other
side
period and i got stuck
blacked out i failed
blacked out when i came to my foot is in
the track
i i'm looking around and down on the
ground my foot is
pinned and i go to try to i mean i'm
down and around i'm trying to pull them
out and i can't get it out and i
could barely talk because of the start
i'm falling and
i do remember that i'm just like
[ __ ] boy i'm looking up at the sky
before
you know trey's coming to start with
ding ding ding ding ding ding
oh my god
this is it for me this is it for me
until god i know
that i'm about to die if this train runs
me over
no way that i could be why
it's just a phenomenon to take my life
now
god threw the thumb on the ground told
me he said decide
whether you want to live or you want to
die
you can miss his foot my foot
was gonna go my life was gonna go i
didn't know how that train was running
it's running on a heavy car heavy
heavy you can hear the coming in the
crowd however
anyways around the tracks i already know
how to stop go
so balls up in the night
curls it's like a little cat curled and
said
hey it comes decide what i'm gonna do in
my life i'm gonna live
i said i never stop smoking cigarettes
that's all i have
and i do the best i can to stop smoking
drugs
because i can see this is gonna kill me
one way or another we're living
the drugs so so the the accident on the
train tracks
you were high you were no you were
suicidal you were
no it was just it was a freak phenomenal
accident it just
happened the foot got pinned and tried
it
and i walked that truck all the time you
know what i'm saying when i was real
and you couldn't pull your foot out of
the shoe or anything i couldn't feel it
i could shoot
or i'm underpinning the track
it was crazy
i'm laying on this ground my foot is in
there the train is about like
let's say 50 feet around here it's right
here
hold my eyes real tight
i'm not gonna die i'm glad you can have
this but just let me know
soon this guy hit across the street of
central
and coming towards me like 10 20 feet
there's my foot i asked walls
as soon as the plane the wheel hit my
ankle and i said
wow i'm hollering and i rolled
i'm under the train
closed captioning not
falls available to the ground to listen
to them
and then drop me over in the gravel of
the dirt in the pit
and i rolled out dragging my body
slagging my leg
trying to get help nobody was around
nobody
and normally it's a lot of traffic
walking
and driving like this day
crazy [ __ ] now same time i
do i'm going back and forth across the
[ __ ] road
train's still going with my foot down
the tracks i'm going back and forth
across the street for the traffic
to notice me tonight to call for me some
help or something to help me
i'm butt naked i'm missing the foot
my flesh is flapping you know
blood everywhere nobody could recognize
me
nobody recognized me to stop nobody
stopped to help me
so one lady
and it takes time to tell a story
because a lot i couldn't remember you
know what i mean i was raped already
and then hitting my head my shoulder
couldn't remember a lot of things um
911 same officers that used to harass me
in the neighborhood they come
so they think they know my name and you
know
a lot of other [ __ ] and because they
also they stopped
bleeding controllably for like within
three minutes
training and she dated me
and got me the harvard ucla
at the time same time there was a
doctor coming from overseas i think they
used to have potato
baboons i got a shadow skin
i'm about to die i'm about to die
all the blood i lost you know getting
ran over and
they rerouted them to harvest ucla and
that's who saved my leg
they cried my bones i gave them all this
because i'm high risk dope i'm harvested
cocaine
i used to help me with my pain already
so my [ __ ] was the only thing that
could control my pain that i was
east they said oh you don't have any
pain
baby i'm high i'm on morphine dim raw i
want whatever it takes for them to get
too much
you know i'm high why would i feel pain
you know and they're doing the best okay
i got the best treatment
in aubry ucla i thank all the staff for
that
i didn't need any training my
stubbornness in my will to live
and to walk again because i use my legs
i use my legs for everything everything
there's my hand there uh
i didn't know how to feel you know
without a leg
after being raised with one at that
point
i didn't know who would say what about
me i know there's
suicide
i'm athlete i need to walk
i need to walk just put me to take these
tubes out of me
you said no you need therapy you're
going to need rehabilitation you're
going to need this they got this
hospital room for all these doctors and
nurses and technicians
no i just said move the trail down
just got up stood right up on his foot
balanced out and hopped to the bathroom
but it's so amazing he said
the doctor came in to signify his um
amputating my leg right and then all
three big positions they walk out
yeah i found you know therapy
give me a pair of questions i'll give
you a wheelchair until we can find out
how i'm gonna get me another leg
because i've seen it on tv that people
walk with these things
like this right here and i want to walk
again
times my whole body up this is my
seventh leg
seven and i haven't been back to get my
current leg
because um situational homelessness
back and forth in industries i got a
good
prosthetic aesthetic doctor um
alexander prosthesis it's one way now
but to hang her up into all of
alexander he technology his own
legs i like him
um ramona scales is his first lady
there's also the manager of this
particular place but still real good to
me
she's been going through a lot of change
with drugs and being homeless
and i plan to get back there to get my
other leg got me a proper
stump this is a socket
all that is titanium it's titanium
um this is like um what's the guy named
heard that uh he had two prosthetic legs
he was like what did he do
he was a jockey or somebody anybody
killed his girlfriend in the bathroom
you remember what i'm talking about
the little short man that killed the
model in the bathroom shot
five times through the wall he had two
prosthetics
anyway this was made like his
and i'm on it right now that's titanium
the rubber i don't walk
the plank pull up here this is the
socket
and my knee is right here right here
and there's a sleeve and then pulls
straight through here
this also came down here i just want
was with the footage titanium with a
rubber
heart but i don't want a shoe i don't
want to put off because i've been in
this bag for like
over two years it's turned up now
because i'm straight on titanium the
rubber is just hanging on
i need a new foot
[Laughter]
and uh i dance i do everything in his
leg
sometimes i don't want to take it off
because i forget that i have it on
until i have sex i'll take a shower
right
and it's been the best thing to happen
to me since i lost
my foot and i'm not gonna lie to you i
walk
better i ban i dance
i
your attitude is great about it i love
my leg
i love my life today i really do
i i've been righteously blessed a lot of
ways and i think i have nothing
and no one the blessings come like
abundance
like yesterday god just works in
a mysterious way you know and
it's exciting and yeah you're working
the streak still
well i work streets when i need me
well i won't stay period because i deal
with people
every day in the streets but you do
business sometimes
a lot of times when did this start
before before the leg accident
escorting started way back when with me
that's what i had been being friends
because they had money i escorted here
at school there
they should be nice buy nice things you
know give me money
socialism i mean you know it's good
well you can get along with people and
you can have a good time and they can
enjoy themselves
so you can valet and school escort i
mean you just got to have a proper
understanding of what you're doing and
why
and be careful and your customers see
your leg and they're they're cool with
it
your personality makes up for it darling
you know when i throw my leg i'm like
give me one minute you don't have a
problem with your leg
i'll be like okay
well we all get along you know
said i wash your balls you wash my back
you know i had a good way to speed up
it's not
anything and everybody but i have a good
question about three or four on the
regular basis like weekly
so it looks so bad yeah what's the
secret to being so happy
with all the that you've seen i've been
through you've had a tough life yeah
um i actually am happy to appoint
to know that it wasn't me
it's not me but it is me
i just wish i could have had it all
going on then until now
but now it's better than never to be
able to relate to myself
if you relate to myself i help me see
someone else
they have relationship that relationship
be a people person
you know you can validate that to make
you happy
like oh my god you spam me from that
well then i'm gonna keep talking about
god but no
she gave me the strength to deal with
society
while i'm living my life i'm homeless
i'm black i'm not so bad off because i'm
educated
and i gotta love me and people they
don't like me don't let me
don't [ __ ] with just move to the side
right okay
move right along yeah i'm happy
i'm happy because now the people that i
thought wouldn't be happy for me or do
for me
they just coming out of the range with
it you know
better now than ever right thank you
nice
tomorrow all right thank you so much so
glad we met
you